- [Instructor] We're told
that Elena wants to build
a one-sample z interval to
estimate what proportion
of computers produced at a
factory have a certain defect.
She chooses a confidence level of 94%.
A random sample of 200
computers shows that
12 computers have the defect.
What critical value z
star should Elena use
to construct this confidence interval?
So before I even ask
you to pause this video,
let me just give you a
little reminder of what
a critical value is.
Remember, the whole point
behind confidence intervals are
we have some true population parameter,
in this case it is the
proportion of computers
that have a defect.
So there's some true
population proportion.
We don't know what that is,
but we try to estimate it.
We take a sample, in
this case it's a sample,
a random sample of 200 computers,
we take a random sample,
and then we estimate this by calculating
the sample proportion.
But then we also wanna
construct a confidence interval.
And remember a confidence interval,
at a 94% confidence level means
that if we were to keep doing this,
and if we were to keep
creating intervals around
these statistics, so maybe
that's the confidence
interval around that one,
maybe if we were to do it again,
that's the confidence
interval around that one,
that 94% that roughly as
I keep doing this over
and over again,
that 90, that roughly
94% of these intervals
are going to overlap with our
true population parameter.
And the way that we do this
is we take the statistic.
Let me just write this in general form,
even if we're not talking
about a proportion.
It could be if we're trying to
estimate the population mean.
So we take our statistic, statistic,
and then we go plus or
minus around that statistic,
plus or minus around that statistic,
and then we say okay how
many standard deviations
for the sampling
distribution do we wanna go
above or beyond?
So the number of standard
deviations we wanna go,
that is our critical value,
and then we multiply
that times the standard
deviation of
the statistic,
of the statistic.
Now in this particular situation,
our statistic is p hat
from this one sample
that Elena made.
So it's that one sample proportion
that she was able to calculate,
plus or minus z star, and
we're gonna think about
which z star because that's
essentially the question,
the critical value.
So plus or minus some critical value
times and what we do
because in order to actually
calculate the true standard deviation of
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions,
well then you actually have to know
the population parameter.
But we don't know that,
so we multiply that
times the standard error
of the statistic.
And we've done this in previous videos.
But the key question here is,
what is our z star?
And what we really
needed to think about is,
assuming that the sampling
distribution is roughly normal,
and this is the mean of
it which would actually
be our true population parameter,
which we do not know.
But how many standard
deviations above and below
the mean in order to capture
94% of the probability?
94% of the area.
So this distance right over here,
where this is 94%,
this number of standard deviations,
that is z star right over here.
Now all we have to really do is look it up
on a z-table,
but even there we have to be careful.
And you should always
be careful which type
of z-table you're using or
if you're using a calculator
function what your
calculator function does.
Because a lot of z-tables will actually
do something like this.
For a given z, they'll say,
what is the total area going all the way
from negative infinity up to including
z standard deviations above,
above the mean?
So when you look up a lot of z-tables,
they will give you, they
will give you this area.
So one way to think about this,
we wanna find the critical value,
we wanna find the z,
that leaves not 6% unshaded in,
but leaves 3% unshaded in.
Where did I get that from?
Well 100% minus 94% is 6%.
But remember this is going to be symmetric
on the left and the right,
so you're gonna want 3%
not shaded in over here
and 3% not shaded in over here.
So when I look at a traditional z-table,
that is viewing it from
this point of view,
this cumulative area,
what I really wanna do is find the z
that is leaving 3% open over here,
which would mean the z that
is filling in 97% over here,
not 94%.
But if I find this z,
but if I were to stop it
right over there as well,
then I would have 3% available there,
and then the true area
that we're filling in
would be 94%.
So that out of the way let's look that up.
What z gives us fills us,
fills in 97% of the area?
So I got a z-table.
This is actually the
one that you would see
if you were say taking AP Statistics.
And we would just look up
where do we get to 97%.
And so it is 97%
looks like it is right about here.
That looks like the closest number.
This is .0006 above it.
This is only .0001 below it.
And so this is,
let's see you would look at the row first.
If we look at the row it is 1.8,
1.88
is our z.
So going back to
this right over here,
if our z is equal to 1.88,
so this is equal to 1.88,
then all of this area
up to and including 1.88
standard deviations above the mean,
that would be 97%.
But if you were to go
1.88 standard deviations
above the mean and 1.88
standard deviations
below the mean,
that would leave 3% open on either side,
and so this would be 94%.
So this would be 94%.
But to answer their question
what critical z value
or what critical value is z star?
Well this is going to be 1.88,
and we're done.